reality is energy doing work
the all is energy doing work
god is energy doing work
infinity eternity is
energy doing work
tada
[Music]
quite simple actually
so simple
energy the power or
ability to do work
and work
being the transfer of energy
so again
energy the power or ability to do work
and work the transfer of energy
so if you ask people
what is the root
what is the ground what is fundamental
what is the substrate
it's energy everyone knows
it's energy but we don't really
talk about it it's
a weird inexplicable no
thing and that's
typically why similar with consciousness
we don't really talk about consciousness
because consciousness is not a
thing and so we don't talk about it
energy again not a thing
or no thing and so we don't talk about
it
water tea glass jars
computers trees mountains cars
school systems the economy
easier to talk about because they are
things commodities are things
stocks or ownership it's a thing
your house is a thing your dog is a
thing
consciousness is not a thing
so everybody breezes past it like it's
nothing but it's the most
fundamental attribute to our existence
it is god
it is the mystery it is infinity
observing and experiencing itself
the universe uses consciousness this
no thing to
witness experience explore its infinite
creation
similar with energy energy is not a
thing
all of this oxygen and nitrogen
here in the air nobody gives a [ __ ]
about it
yet you're inhaling it
20 000 times a day
and then that co2 goes into
the photosynthesis cycle phytoplankton
and trees provide you back
with the o2 again but nobody cares
because it's energy it's not a
thing it's just here
and i'm energy your energy
god is energy this is all energy there
are no borders there's no separation
and that's how you can just
cut through
all ignorance directly to being a
gnostic being
directly to vidya
directly to knowledge of the nature of
reality
directly
you can't draw any lines there are no
boundaries this is all one field
interpenetrating itself
this is energy doing work reality is
energy doing work it's not a
thing and because it's not a thing and
because you can't draw
boundaries you're confused
and the fastest way is to just admit i'm
confused
i don't get it
perfect the moment that you admit
that you don't understand energy you
open your
heart to the nature of reality because
what you're doing is you're taking
the separate person that you thought you
were
this illusion this mirage and you're
saying okay
game on i don't know my heart is open
i am interested in self-inquiry i'm
interested in metaphysics i'm interested
in consciousness the nature of reality
i will investigate and upon
simply the openness you're liberating
yourself
from the contracted scripts that you've
been running
in your discursive thinking
that is so endlessly consuming your life
with your character i me my mind
likes dislikes and differences
perpetually
you basically create a cessation
of said discursive thinking
so that you can go what is the nature of
this
what is the nature of this and when you
do that you
uncover that this is not a thing it's no
thing
appearing
reality is energy doing work reality is
no thing
the very power or ability
to transfer energy
god is the ultimate
endless transfer of energy
exploratively
let's try this do let's try that do
let's try this
do we didn't learn that yet do let's
learn that new thing
constantly learning reality is a school
an
eternal school these are playful
child-like analogies you'll never come
to the end of
you'll never come to the end of
something that is unbounded
a no thing that is unbounded and
unconditionally free
you'll never come to the end of
exploration no matter what
so god is like the ultimate chef
constantly trying all of these different
food recipes
tasting it oh that was good that
universe with those
mind body spirit complexes that are dna
encoded atcg
with four limbs two eyes bounded to
these rocks orbiting stars
that was a good universe design i like
that it's like an amount of salt and
pepper
that you then say was really good and
then you say i'm gonna do that on my
next dish
and i'm gonna try something new maybe
i'm gonna sprinkle in
a little bit of cumin this time maybe
i'm gonna add
some little bit of jalapeno for some
spice
baby and you try something new
simple as that fam
so simple
the mystery talking to the mystery
infinity talking to infinity god
talking to itself
it's total unilocality
everything is interpenetrating
everything else
that's what energy doing work is
there's no boundary
you've taken a hundred inhales
never once did you go oh the oxygen was
not
me and then it became me and then
exhaling the co2 it did not become me
okay this water is not me right now this
tea but now
now it's me temporarily until i urinate
it
nobody thinks that because it doesn't
exist
it's an illusion it's an imagination
it's a mirage of
the mind
and the same thing's true between two
people there is no
boundary none zero
zilch nada no separation
no separation no separation is
the game of creation no separation
is the game of creation no separation is
the riddle of creation
no separation is the riddle of creation
seriously so
simple
so when you look at
another recognize that it's energy
talking to energy
it's just reality talking to reality
life
talking to life the mystery talking to
the mystery
infinity talking to infinity emptiness
talking to emptiness
that is uniquely being expressed as some
sort of character and another sort of
character the appearance of two
separate characters but underlying it
is one intelligence talking to itself
energy
doing work so simple
so that's the nature you can
literally look at what spirituality has
been saying
about infinity about god about eternity
about dao about brahman
about consciousness about awareness
and you can begin looking at that from a
quantum mechanical scientific
perspective and you're like
well i guess quantum mechanics and
mysticism are
two sides of the same coin that are
ultimately one coin
there you go seriously if you get
if you can synthesize science and
spirituality if you can synthesize
materialism and consciousness which are
ultimately again
one thing but if you can do that you can
penetrate
mainstream cultural zeitgeist
with the nature of reality which is what
the show
simulation is all about ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding
it's the winner you gotta be a synthesis
signs and spirituality are one quantum
mechanics and mysticism are one
materialism and consciousness are one
and so you can simply look at what
science has understood the last hundred
years
and you can use the understanding
of quantum mechanics to recognize that
all
is energy all
is energy doing work reality is energy
doing work
and you'll never come to the end of
all of the possible combinations of
energy doing work
just ask yourself a logical question how
many different
combinations are possible of energy
doing work
ask yourself you can ask yourself
another simple question
how many combinations of
musical notes can you put into a song
endless
how many different
images can you stitch together into a
movie
and list infinite
how many different ways can you vibrate
vocal cords
to create language how many
endless infinite
and so that's the game you'll never
come to the end of the amount
of ways that energy can do work
that god can play with itself that
infinity or a singularity
can play with itself similar to the
analogy we were using with the chef
you'll never come to the end of all the
different ways you can put together food
into recipes
you look at this right now there have
been 8 billion
humans that are alive right now
and there were about a hundred billion
that lived and died before us today
so about 108 billion total humans have
been alive here on this rock
in this creation and then you ask okay
well how many different combinations are
there
to their appearance endless even the 108
billion humans that have lived and died
have had certain
appearances of costumes
how many different ways can you put
together hair how many different ways
can you put together eyes
how many different ways can you put
together facial features how many
different ways can you string together
these
little symbols into a name four symbols
can be
john five symbols can be susie
endless ways to string together these
symbols into names of these costumes
but underneath of all of the costumes is
the same
essence it's the same intelligence under
all costumes
you have the same intelligence that is
currently happening
that the intelligence across the entire
planet
across the entire universe it's one
intelligence all of it it's energy
doing work realities energy doing work
the all god dao brahman
the universal wave function is just
energy
doing work
and again looking at things like zero
point energy
how many different ways can that zero
point energy modulate
and create the appearance of form of
name of
shape endless that's what this is
that's what this is the very
no thing appearing like things
no thing appearing like things emptiness
is form and form is emptiness
there you go you'll never get beyond
this perfection of wisdom in buddhism
you'll never get past it
emptiness is form form is emptiness
you're covering the two
poles which are ultimately the same
thing
it covers duality and non-duality
in the same sutra
you'll never get past it
and so quantum mechanics is now
confirming buddhist heart sutra
or another way of saying this is that
this turn
inward towards consciousness away from
physicalism
is now closing the loop of
self-awareness
on how it is god and how
god is simultaneously both
the earth and the universe while it's
also the consciousness and awareness
it's both again it's all energy
there's no distinction between
physicalism and idealism or
consciousness
there's no distinction between science
and form and
empty cognizance which is
suffused with awareness
there's no distinction all dualities
collapse into
all his energy and this was what is
again
meant by dependent origination in
buddhism
everything is simply energy
interpenetrating itself everything is
interdependent
the first link independent origination
is do you know the essence do you know
that this is
empty cognizance do you know
that this is infinity do you know that
this intelligence is shared
do you know that this is all energy
interpenetrating itself
doing work because if you don't know
that
then it's ignorance and then you think
you're a separate person
and so that's the first link is you
create i
me my mind you create all of these
attributes you create all of these
identities
and then you have likes and dislikes and
indifferences cravings aversions
and apathy's and then you spend your
entire
life trying to extract peace and
happiness
from the external world you try and get
worthiness or validation
or have some sort of experience or
substance or materialistic possession or
relationship to make you fulfilled
because that very first link in
dependent origination
you don't know the true nature of
reality you're not a gnostic being
you're ignorant and that's why in your
expression
is suffering
there's a big emotional guidance system
that's working where if you're
experiencing suffering that means
that you're being ignorant turn inward
recognize that this is god
you are already always god you are
already
always unconditionally free singularity
so simple right
surrender to it
just devotionally
you're already the one infinite creator
you're already the one infinite
intelligence
you're already this one infinite energy
exploring
once you unite more and more
intimately and dissolve every single
last
little tiny bit of separation
once no sensation can create a
trigger cascade in your neurology
creating discursive thinking and craving
an aversion
and indifferences once you've completely
surrendered all of your character all of
your costume
all of your identities and attributes
you merge more and more unitingly
yoga mysticism henosis
in this turn inward
also called purification purifying all
of the separation and all of the
distortion
and then you're like this beautiful
natural state expression of
creation innocent wise
child-like playful sage-like
and just peaceful equanimous joyful
blissful radiating enlightened you are
the sun
that just illuminates beautifully
and serves beautiful
pure service to others
that are actually yourself because you
know
they are you and you are them
and that's what makes the service so
is that you know there's no separation
you've dissolved all separation
in your being in your beingness you've
dissolved all separation
not as an intellectual thought it starts
that way
and then it works more and more into
your heart so you become enlightened
in the mind and then you become
enlightened in the heart and you can
dance and sing and play and you actually
have dissolved that separation between
people and then you're enlightened in
the gut
and it's so visceral energy doing work
becomes your reality infinity [ __ ]
itself
interpenetrating itself energetically
becomes your reality
and you look at this biological
archetype of things like
cosmogenesis abiogenesis you look at
things like the cell the single cell
that proliferated into all of these
species you look at fungal networks
you look at how our internet
is just like that you look at how
bitcoin cryptocurrency and
decentralization are just like that
humans are just like that we are just
like that we are just
that same biological archetype but we
created all of this artificial
separation which is the name of the game
it's the one infinite intelligence
mystery falling asleep
and contracting its energy and then
breaking out of its mirage illusion to
this liberated energy
it's the whole game that we play
and so see reality as energy doing work
see that the combinatorics are
endless see that there's no separation
whatsoever no separation is the game of
creation
no separation is the riddle of creation
boom and then that's it it's a gnostic
being
right there right then and there it's so
close to you
it's like the difference between the
light and the shadow
such a thin line
you see that tiny little difference
between the light and the shadow
there's no true line that separates them
all it requires is your energy
to turn on itself and be like okay i am
energy but i've created all of
this person and this identity
and all these attributes my name and my
career
and my likes and dislikes and i now
fight for worthiness and validation
and all these things and then you
recognize oh i'm just
energy this whole reality is just energy
it's all one
unbounded energy playing with itself
tension gone liberation release
moksha end
of dukkha liberation from suffering baby
anata non-self no self
energy playing with itself
doesn't have these separate islands
of selfs
makes a lot of sense all you gotta do is
do self inquiry into the energy system
that this is
cool pretty simple so
my assignment is to do self inquiry into
the energy system that this is
yes that's your assignment that's your
homework
pretty simple self inquiry
atma vichara into
who am i what is i
who is i
deconstructing yourself
okay so if i'm if this is all energy
i've just been creating these mirages
and these illusions and these
attachments to
my little string of four five or six
symbols
that i've put together around my name of
a piece of life
and then you realize how much you've
created your entire daily
agenda around that little
five or six symbol strung together
naming a piece of life
to go out into the world and then get
validated by other pieces of life
it's insanity it's illusion it's mirage
and the turn inward self-inquiry
into this one infinite unbounded energy
that this
is is the name of the game win the game
awaken wake up wake
up wake up wake up wake up
simple you're already it
just recognize that you're this
unbounded energy
you're already it just recognize you're
this unbounded energy
you are me i am you right now
this is completely unilocal this is all
god one unbounded energy system
interpenetrating itself doing work
this is the mystery talking to itself
god talking to itself this is why
it's so beautiful just tune into this
message
and recognize it right here right now
one energy talking to itself
one energy talking to itself one energy
doing work one energy
doing work that's the game
that's it dissolve all separation
dissolve it all
win the game all is
energy doing work that's it
energy transferrings happening that's it
i appeared to be more blocked
five years ago ten years ago and then i
learned
from less blocked people that were
liberated gnostic beings
now i am less blocked
and liberated and now i am
serving myself all of
you that are me communicating this
message
so that you if you feel blocked
can become liberated just like happened
to me five ten years ago see that
energy transfer happening that's all
this is
energy was transferred here five and ten
years ago
by people that were liberated and now me
being liberated am transferring energy
to you
becoming more liberated that's it but
don't take
five years don't take 10 years you can
right now just recognize everything that
i've associated with my
identity is completely a mirage it's
completely an illusion
and all that really truly at the end of
the day
is is just one infinite intelligence
interpenetrating itself
that's it reality is energy doing work
all is energy doing work
done done
and then treat it that way be it be it
be it realize and be realize
and be realize and be be
be that's it that's it
realize and be
so all you see is
energy doing work you see all as you
and that's it that's enlightenment
that's awakening
enjoy that's metaphysics
101 consciousness 101 awakening 101
enlightenment 101
and it has everything to do with science
as well
it has everything to do with meeting the
sustainable development goals it has
everything to do with
meeting the esg's as well
the environmental social governances
around the planet
it has everything to do with creating
the architectures that maximize basic
needs
as we awaken to being one energy doing
work
all of a sudden we create more and more
of this urge
within us to serve creation to create
these decentralized
fractional ownership inclusive
stakeholding architectures
that enable all of us
this one intelligence to blossom fully
simple stuff simple stuff
right here right now
all is energy doing work
reality is energy doing work
no separation is the riddle
of creation
beautiful infinite love
thank you will
never come to the end of exploration
simple as that infinity eternity
one infinite creator one unbounded
unconditionally free mystery singularity
god
if the video brought you value give it a
like subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would deeply resonate
with
all these other selves serve them
especially those that are materialistic
that are scientific
this will help them understand oneness
leave a comment below would love to hear
from you
and check out the links in the bio below
as well
you can support us there cross our
endeavors
that's all infinite love so simple
truly this is love talking to love
truth talking to truth reality talking
to reality
god talking to god life talking to life
energy talking to
energy